Candice is with us in Dallas hi Candice
how are you hi baby I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay so
I have five credit cards some with lower
balances some with higher balances the
ones with the higher balance 13,000
around $13,000 has a higher APR what I
want to do is apply the minimum payment
of about three hundred eighty six
dollars a month that I pay on the higher
balance with the higher APR towards the
lower balance lower APR carts first so
then I can snowball that money into the
higher ones when once I get rid of the
lower ones but I want to know if that's
a good idea I'm not looking for
purchasing anything major in the next
couple years I have a house cars are
paid off but we have three kids and we
are trying to put two and daycare at
once and I just don't have the monthly
income to do so what's your household
income our household income is roughly a
hundred nine thousand dollars mm-hmm how
much debt do you have not counting your
house not counting my house my husband
has a student loan of roughly a hundred
thousand dollars there's more yeah and
then our credit cards total to about
thirty one thousand okay you're not
doing a written budget
I do do my written budget every month
there's enough money here to pay these
bills a hundred and nine thousand dollar
income you can pay that student loan
payment and you can pay $31,000 with a
credit card debt that's doable there's
room in this budget I don't know what
you're spending your money on so I am
able to pay it no I'm only paying the
minimum or all the cards right now
that's what you need to do first first
thing you do is you pay all your
minimums and then after that you make a
list of your debts smallest to largest
while you're paying minimums on
everything you pay all the extra you can
on your smallest debt APR does not enter
into this discussion okay
good but you should get this debt
reduced really really sighs I don't
think so but the other problem is we're
looking to put our we have to put our
youngest into daycare because our the
childcare provider we have now can no
longer keeper so we don't have any money
to free up to put her into
here and that's part of the problem
right now with how much was your house
payment our house name is our $2,000 oh
yeah else you can't afford so I recently
a lot of that was with my escrow account
with my homeowner's insurance which I
just recently changed so that won't come
into effect until the spring because
they've already paid it out in full and
I changed it like I guess a little too
late pretty much so I won't see the
benefit of that until next year yeah
okay um here's the thing you have to get
yourself in a position where your income
versus your outgo leaves your room to
clear up a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars worth of debt you have to you
cannot just excite oh I have a daycare
problem oh I have up this problem
oh no that problem you can't you just
can't do that you're not at the mercy of
this math this math is at the mercy of
you and so if you cannot cut lifestyle
and cut things out of your budget enough
to be able to attack this ridiculous
amount of debt you all have then you
probably going to sell your house
because you have a very high house
payment okay your house payments more
than 1/4 of your take-home pay
yeah and a lot of those are property
taxes yeah yeah and so that's what's
squeezing you you've got to get the
income up or they out go down somewhere
okay because you've got to find some
margin in here otherwise we're just
treading water right and that's you know
that's just a rat in a wheel and
mathematically you don't want just run
run run run run run and have a heart
attack and die I mean that's not that's
no life to be a rat in a wheel so we've
got again it's kind of the mathematical
logjam these last two callers that
you've got to do something radical so
hey thanks for the call
I appreciate you joining us